Der Rasenfunk – Kurzpass. In der Ligue 1 ist schon wieder so einiges passiert. Sieben Spieltage sind schon gespielt. Wir wollen drauf blicken zusammen mit David Frogier de Ponlevoy von 93. Schön, dass du mit dabei bist. Ich hoffe, du verzeihst mir den kleinen, da habe ich den ersten Namenshauptler schon im Intro drin.
Ja, wir haben gerade schon über Namen gesprochen. Er wartet nichts, Leute. Ich werde ausländische Spieler französisch aussprechen und vielleicht sogar einige Franzosenfalsen aussprechen, weil ich sie nur in der Zeitung gelesen habe.
Das Gute ist, du hast ja mich als Gegenpart und der schafft es ja nicht mal, seinen Gast ordentlich anzukündigen. Deswegen schön, dass du da bist, David, und mach dir keinen Kopf wegen deiner Namen. Wir wuscheln uns da irgendwie durch.
Das ist ein Mittelstück, der von Sevilla kam, für alle diejenigen, die jetzt nicht gleich mit dem Namen Ben Yedder etwas anfangen können.
Bakayoko ist zurück aus der großen Meistermannschaft. Das zumindest ist, allerdings nur Gelin von Chelsea. Das freut einen. Aber ansonsten sind da so viele großartige Namen, die dann, sobald sie da sind, das ist so ein bisschen das HSV-Syndrom irgendwie, sobald sie da sind, funktioniert es nicht. Also Jadim ist auch hart angezählt, das merkt man auch, wenn man…
Zum Wider.
Ja, mal wieder, genau. Ich verfolge diverse Monaco-Fans auf Twitter und so. Und da ist nicht mehr viel Liebe für den einzigen Superhelden Jadim vorhanden.
Der ja schon mal entlassen war.
Genau.
Dann kam Thierry Henry und dann kam Jadam wieder mit zurück.
Kam Jadim zurück, genau. Ich bin sicher, das war ja jeweils mit Millionen Abfindungen verbunden, sowohl Jadim zu entlassen als auch Thierry Henry zu entlassen. Ich bin sicher, das wäre aktuell wieder der Fall. Also es ist ein Trauerspiel eigentlich. Es ist ein absolutes Trauerspiel, was mit dieser Mannschaft passiert, die ja eigentlich über Jahrzehnte für Spielkultur stand.
Und auch für ein gelungenes Scouting ja eigentlich durchaus. Also aus Monaco kamen ja häufig die Talente, die vorher nicht auf dem Radar der großen Vereine waren.
Wobei gesagt, in den letzten Jahren kamen sie unter anderem wegen Louis Campos. Und der ist eben jetzt bei Lidl. Also es ist nicht so, dass im Gottes Willen, Monaco war tatsächlich auch schon vorher durchaus eine Talentschmiede. Aber von den letzten Winter-Transfers, die geholt worden sind in Monaco, ist eigentlich nur Gessen Martins ein Erfolg. Der Rest ist entweder direkt wieder weitergegangen oder sitzt noch sinnlos auf der Bank rum. Tielemanns.
Der Kader ist krass. Also der Kader ist so, dass man in sich durchgeht und denkt, in einer Fußballsimulation könnte man durchaus mit Monaco spielen. Aber da ist es ja nicht so wie eine Realität, dass die dann schlechter sind als ihre Werte. Weil du hast mit Subasic ja eigentlich gerade verletzt, aber einen guten Torhüter, Benagio ist da der Ersatz.
Le Compte war eigentlich großartig für Montpellier jetzt. Subasic und Benagio sind ja beide so die etwas angezählten, älteren Torwart, die ich überzeugen konnte. Und Le Compte ist wirklich großartig. Also eigentlich war er.
Und dann hast du Kami Glick als Kapitän, den kennt man auch.
Auch ein fürchterlicher Schatten seiner selbst.
Eigentlich als Bollwerk, daneben Naldo. Wir alle wissen im Guten wie im Schlechten, was Naldo kann. Und so richtig Benjamin Hendricks, darf man nicht vergessen, von Leverkusen damals noch zu Monaco gewechselt. Hört man jetzt auch in Deutschland gar nichts mehr davon. Dann hast du eben Baka Joko zurückgeholt aus der Meisterschaft. Du hast Fabregas im Mittelfeld, Adrian Silva. Du hast Golovin. Wir alle wissen, wie viele Sprits der angezogen hat während der Weltmeisterschaft.
Er findet sich allerdings jetzt. Der war ja auch einer der großen Enttäuschungen nach seinem Transfer direkt. Und mittlerweile, also ich wage da noch keine, Schwalbe macht noch keinen Sommer. Aber so in den letzten Spielen, in den letzten Wochen, das sieht richtig gut aus gerade, was der auf den Platz bringt. Endlich.
Also es ist schon, es ist ein bisschen ein Mysterium. Ben Yedda haben wir schon angesprochen. Dann Jean-Claude Kevin Augustin ist von Rabah Leipzig noch zu Monaco gewechselt. Ohne dass ich jetzt sagen würde, der reiht sich da schon direkt neben Ben Yedda ein in der Hierarchie. Aber um zu zeigen, also Monaco war ja sehr aktiv auf dem Transfermarkt und das funktioniert mal wieder sehr, sehr wenig. Ein Sieg, drei Unentschieden, drei Niederlagen. Über Monaco werden wir auch wieder viel reden, David. Das nächste Mal werden wir dann auch noch über Saint Etienne sprechen. Die stehen aktuell auch nicht gut da, nämlich noch schlechter als Monaco. Und wir erinnern uns, in der letzten Saison waren die ja auf Tabellenplatz 4. Die sind gerade neunzehntelang. Aber alle können wir jetzt nicht besprechen. Ihr habt es gemerkt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, auch wenn man es immer nicht so glauben mag, auch in der Liga ist so viel passiert, dass man da locker mehrere Stunden drüber sprechen könnte. Ich bin froh, David, dass ich das immer mit dir machen kann in dieser schönen Runde. Und das hat, wie immer, großen Spaß gemacht. Danke dir, dass du mit dabei warst.
Sehr gerne. Und wie viel haben wir die Stunden jetzt gerissen?
3 Minuten, 4 Minuten. Wir laufen gerade in die vierte Minute rein. Das wird gerade noch so gehen. Das war David Frogier de Ponlevoy als at n'gungongvn auf Twitter. Und ihr hört natürlich 3.90. Da könnt ihr David zusammen mit den anderen drei Verrückten jede Woche hören. David, vielen Dank dir für deine Zeit. Und euch lieben Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Es geht dann weiter im Rasenfunk mit einer Schlusskonferenz zur Bundesliga. Und dann gibt es sicherlich auch bald den nächsten Kurzpass und hoffentlich auch Tribütengespräche.